The West Wing was evacuated on Sunday
after a bag of white powder was
discovered in the White House the
evacuation was brief however after
officials remembered that Hunter Biden
doesn't snort Anthrax as far as We Know
the white powder turned out to be
nothing more than a first son favorite
booger sugar you know what I'm talking
about
some Colombian nose candy if you catch
my drift little Yale College baking soda
if you can infer my meaning I'm talking
about Coke
which means
that since the president's infamously
unrepentant dirt bag of a sun had been
visiting the White House that very
weekend A lot of people came to
conclusions about how the cocaine got
there MSNBC however
is shocked
and turning to some breaking news we
have just learned that a formal lab has
confirmed the suspicion that that white
powdery substance found in the west wing
on Sunday was in fact positive for
cocaine the discovery led to a brief
evacuation of the White House Sunday
night joining us now is NBC White House
correspondent Mike memley so Mike where
do things stand now this is so unusual
you and I have covered the White House
for years I can't even
fathom anything like this having been
found before In The West Wing and I go
back to the 70s at the White House so
this is pretty pretty wild
it's absolutely extraordinary Andrea and
this new conclusive test confirms what
had been the preliminary field test
conducted by DC fire Personnel who were
called in on Sunday night after the
discovery of this suspicious substance
by a uniformed officer in the Secret
Service that was conducting a routine
patrol of the White House and so to
recap on the developments from that
we've been reporting on yesterday this
was found we understand in a highly
trafficked common area of the West Wing
it's an area where individuals
especially visitors individuals who may
be coming for for instance a private
tour yeah we just but it's it's hard to
fathom
we just don't know
how on Earth cocaine made its way into
the Biden White House
who knows
who knows not to be outdone in
implausibility a law enforcement
official has gone on record to say that
the cocaine culprit is unlikely ever to
be found
because put the put the first son aside
for a second
because the culprit whoever he is in any
case is a friend of Joe Biden the only
people who make it into the West Wing
these days are friends and allies of Joe
Biden and the Democrats
and Democrat criminals generally
speaking with very few exceptions don't
face consequences because they don't get
charged because they don't get arrested
because they're usually not even
investigated conservatives have the book
thrown at us for even slightly
approaching the line of legality while
the libs get off scot-free when they
cross the line and even when they snort
it up behind them I'm Michael Knowles
this the Michael Knowles show
thank you
[Music]
welcome back to the show there's a
wonderful clip in this ongoing debate
over affirmative action and Harvard
admissions of Joy Reed who I just
learned Joy read is in this MSNBC
talking head apparently she went to
Harvard and she admits the only reason
she got in is because of affirmative
action and then she proves it when she
demonstrates that she doesn't even know
what affirmative action is this is so
we'll we'll get to that in a bit first
though speaking of intoxicants
Bud Light is selling for less than water
right now in some places according to
Andy Wagner the manager of Glenn
Miller's beer and soda Warehouse in
Lemoyne Pennsylvania
speaking to the New York Times he says
at this point it's cheaper than some of
the cases of water we're selling in the
back
it's just not moving like it used to
it's not that these people have stopped
drinking beer they just stopped buying
Bud Light
now according to this guy he said
Anheuser-Busch broke bar rules which
means no politics no religion number
this was the number one best-selling
beer in America for over 20 years now
it's fallen and it's plummeting the the
sales continue to fall and uh Modelo
Especial has overtaken Bud Light is the
number one beer in America and now Bud
Light is selling in some places cheaper
than water this is really encouraging
not only because of what it says about
Americans views of the pride stuff
conservatives abilities to boycott a
company and really bring them to heal
but because it reminds us
not to despair because it reminds us
that bad systems can't go on forever
because it reminds us that there
actually are consequences for bad stupid
misguided actions that are not in accord
with reality and I think we
conservatives I'll include myself in
this we sometimes are tempted to despair
because we see the first family getting
away with murder well sorry I'm not
talking about the clintons I'm talking
about the Biden so they get away with
you know bribery and Corruption and
drugs and all this kind of stuff and
they just get away with it and and
they're not held to account ever
meanwhile Midwestern grannies who crack
probably not a Bud Light in the capital
rotunda they get thrown in solitary
confinement they have the book thrown at
them because of General number six then
we just look at this and we say goodness
gracious it's so Preposterous the kinds
of ideologies some of which we're not
allowed to talk about on big Tech
anymore so you got to go to daily
wire.com to hear the commentary on that
but certain ideologies that are very
much in the news are manifestly absurd
and yet The Establishment continues to
push them it seems like without any real
consequence whatsoever they don't they
don't seem in any way accountable to the
people and yet
sometimes this is the the great
conservative consolation
reality reasserts itself eventually
there can be a lot of time and a lot of
pain before reality research itself but
it does and now you're seeing this
especially as Bud Light collapses so Bud
Light
they're trying almost everything to
resuscitate their brand and they're
catching a lot of flack for almost
everything they do
Bud Light comes out initially and they
sort of don't quite not exactly
apologize
then they double down then they publish
an ad about horses or something which
totally sidesteps the issue then they
publish this ad with a bunch of grunting
rube idiot hick deplorable irredeemables
just like stumbling and bumbling over
themselves as though that was going to
ingratiate them back with their customer
base and now Bud Light is is using
Fallen Soldiers as a last-ditch effort
to resuscitate the brand
[Music]
second tour in Iraq is an F-16 pilot I
witnessed a family
as their fallen soldier returned home
[Music]
I felt a calling to help
Budweiser has believed in folds of Honor
for 13 years
today we honor our veterans
and the 44 000 scholarships awarded to
their families
that's enough to fill this Stadium
Missouri class of 22. Gabby back in
2023. Landon class of 2025.
service never stops and neither will we
like Bud Light this commercial is
almost completely tasteless
why because this is a bad charity no
it's a great charity because it's bad
that Bud Light has done any money to it
no Bud Light should donate money to it
because it's bad that Bud Light is
mentioning that they're donating money
to it no I don't even totally mind that
if a company is doing that they should
do it in a more graceful subtle way
but because this advertisement was
produced and aired with one purpose and
one purpose only and that is to
win back customers after the Dylan
Mulvaney Fiasco
there is only one way out of the Dylan
Mulvaney Fiasco there's only one way out
it's not ads with horses it's not
presenting
white men in the South as bumbling
fumbling idiots don't know who thought
that was a good idea it's not
talking about the Fallen Soldiers and
how much you do for the families of the
Fallen Soldiers you know the one way out
of this the only shot I'm not saying
it'll even work the only shot that Bud
Light has out of the Dylan Mulvaney
Fiasco
apologize
apologize say you don't believe in that
stuff you don't stand for that kind of
absurdity you're not pushing that
radical sexual agenda on people you're
sorry that you ever did it you've taken
actions to correct that you don't hate
your customers you don't think that
they're Frat Boys and rude blue-collar
idiots you you need to apologize and you
need to clearly State what you believe
there's no there's no avoiding the
political issue you've injected yourself
into this contentious political debate
and this is a debate on this particular
sexual ideology that we're not allowed
to mention the name of on big Tech
platforms there is no way of trying to
just remain neutral and appease
everybody this is a binary option do you
support this radical false sexual
ideology or or not
which is it you've got to make it it's
binary I know we talk about non-binary
things these days it's a binary choice
and a bud light's caught between a rock
and a hard place because the vast
majority of people don't accept this
radical sexual ideology that we all know
is false but the elites the people with
the money the big asset managers and the
big people who control the media and the
political order and the education
systems and all the rest of it they do
support the radical ideology
and the customers are the many the
people who don't support it but the
investors and the advertisers and the
platform owners they're the ones who do
support it and so Bud Light is caught
here well then just stop then just stop
then give it up stop making these
tasteless ads they're going to irritate
your customer base even more then just
don't do anything and wait it out and
hope people forget that's your that's
your only other option if you want to
try to resuscitate the brand there's
there's only one way
if you really wanted to do it Bud Light
would just air a commercial of my CPAC
speech that caused a little
consternation on the right over this
particular on the left rather over this
particular issue if Bud Light really
wanted to correct things with the base
Bud Light would air a trailer for The
what is a Woman movie as a commercial
okay that would really do at the very
least though just apologize to say yeah
we were wrong we don't believe that
sorry boys or boys girls or girls beers
beer please buy us again and cars are
cars you know when you want to buy a car
you got to check out carsing right now
go to carsagen.com Knowles buying a new
car can be a stressful experience for
anyone especially if you're a first-time
buyer or have no credit before you walk
into a dealership and spend the entire
day with the crowd stress and potential
to not even find the right car you need
to check out carzing carzing is
completely changing the way you buy a
car online by partnering with Credit
Agencies lenders and over 25 000 dealers
Nationwide charising provides you with
everything you need before stepping foot
into a dealership once you find the
right car at your ideal by budget all
you have to do is bring your saved deal
voucher with you to the dealership to
finalize your next ride it's super
simple even if you are not in the market
for a new car you should check out
carsing anyway karzing's online window
shopping experience goes beyond mirror
images you can dive deep into each
vehicle's specifications features and
performance capabilities zoom in on the
craftsmanship of the Interior Marvel at
The Cutting Edge technology and admire
the meticulous attention to detail that
sets these automobiles apart from the
rest carzing helps make your experience
faster cheaper and less stressful go to
carson.com Knowles find the best deals
near you coursing.com Knowles
speaking of economic shifts
great news that is not being reported
very much
about our political order this is such
great news it's not a sexy issue like a
beer company going woke or something so
people aren't talking but this is so
this is such a big win for conservatives
the northeast of America which has been
the dominant economic leader the
PowerHouse of America for I don't know
about as long as I can remember
is no longer the main driver of the
American economy do you know which
region is
the South
the liberal Northeast region
has lost its economic dominance
the conservative region the South has
taken it
why is that
because people are leaving the Northeast
because the Northeast has become
unlivable very difficult with stupid
regulations and stupid taxes and stupid
social policies especially the stupid
social policies
they're moving to the South which is not
only Freer economically but perhaps more
importantly it's an it's still an
ordered Society
it's still a normal place where you can
live a normal life and I know all we
ever talk about is how well we've got
lower taxes here you know or hey we've
got fewer regulations so it's easier to
do business and that's true and those
were big motivating factors that got a
lot of us conservatives myself included
to leave liberal places and to move here
to Tennessee or Texas or Georgia or
Florida or these other places too but
more than that
it's the social stuff when people ask me
hey Michael how do you like Tennessee I
say I love Tennessee I said do you plan
to stay there I totally plan to stay
here why is that
I don't say because I have a little bit
more money which I do I do have a little
bit more money here because there's no
state income tax
what I always say is because I can raise
a family here because it's a nice normal
place to live because I love my
neighbors because there's a community
here because I love my Parish because I
because it's normal here and people
smile and are nice and talk about things
in a normal way
and it turns out that normality
and living in accordance with reality
is good for business too we can serve it
as we we fall for the same economics
exaltation that the leftists and even
that the marxists do the marxists
primary mistake was viewing man as
essentially an economic creature but man
is not essentially an economic reach or
man is made in the image and likeness of
God and there's a lot more to life than
money so we want a good economy but we
want that good economy in service of a
good society and a good life
you don't want to put the cart before
the horse
and when you think about economics first
things are going to get out of whack you
see this not only on the left but even
on the right when conservatives try to
avoid the social issues and they just
wanted to talk about
occupational licensing reform or
whatever then we lost all of our power
and Society spun totally out of control
what we have learned I think in the last
10 years especially on the right is that
social issues are economic issues
there's you're not going to fix the
economic problem by having a social
truce or anything like that the social
issues do we respect life do we know
what marriage is do we support families
do we support growing families and
growing the Next Generation do we
recognize borders and the distinction
between a citizenry and foreign peoples
do we if we don't do that
then you can have all the economic
tinkering in the world it's not going to
fix your Society things are going to
continue to degrade
so now
Florida Georgia North Carolina South
Carolina my state of Tennessee and Texas
which is all my ex that's where All My
Exes Live they have economically
overtaken
Boston New York City Washington DC the
Northeast according to Bloomberg
the population in the Southeast grew by
2.2 million people in the last two years
it's the same consolation that we were
just talking about with Bud Light
bad systems can't go on forever
political orders always change and and
conservatives used to not like that last
part of it because we used to want to
believe hey look the America of
1958 that has to go on forever the uh
the America not even of 1778 not even of
1888 but of 19 mid 1950s America that is
the Eternal political order it has to go
on forever and any deviation from that
whatsoever is awful and terrible and a
violation of everything we hold dear and
we used to lament when the left would
tell us well that's not how politics
Works things change all the time we say
no we don't want it to change we want it
to remain exactly the same well yeah
it's
it's very sad to know that political
orders always have to change when things
are good but when things are bad and
decadent and corrupted as they are right
now then it's a great
consolation and hope to know that
political orders none of them not the
best one not the worst one none of them
go on forever
and also money talks and Bs walks and so
as the South as the conservative part of
the country gains more economic power
the south is going to be able to throw
its political weight around a little bit
more than we have in the past just as
the liberal Northeast was able to throw
its political weight around and dominate
the country for the last 100 years
now speaking of bad systems and speaking
of the South great news out of Virginia
PornHub has just suspended its service
in Virginia
great story just came out this is going
around Twitter and an email
from PornHub I did not receive this
email I do although sometimes Libs find
my email address and they sign me up for
all sorts of nasty little things I have
to then unsubscribe for it's very
frustrating I mercifully have not been
signed up for this one not recently at
least and I I now I know I know saying
that I know I'm going to just get a
flood of sign ups for this evil website
but it doesn't even really matter
because this website is going down
because people are throwing their
economic and political weight around to
destroy PornHub and the Liberals are
upset about that and some of the
Libertarians are probably upset about
that but the conservatives are going to
be thrilled about that what does PornHub
say they say dear user as you may know
your elected officials in Virginia are
requiring us to verify your age before
allowing you access to our website while
safety and compliance are at the
Forefront of our mission
hold on put up we gotta
forget even the idea that safety and
compliance are really important to
PornHub
what the hell is our mission what is our
mission at PornHub
take porn out of it for a second this is
so grating about all Millennial
companies oh they always have to have a
mission you know they're just they're
all on a social Mission you could have
you could have like an accounting firm
they say well our social mission is to
improve the world and to stop climate
change and to spread pride and progress
and we have a mission and and that's
even true of smut Peddlers like PornHub
what's your mission your mission is to
arouse the lusts of men and to exploit
women and sexually trafficked people
that's your vision and to make money
doing it okay so they say safety in
compliance are at the Forefront of our
mission
but giving your ID card every time you
want to visit an adult platform is not
the most effective solution until a real
solution is offered well we got a
solution PornHub uh We've made the
difficult decision to completely disable
access to our website in Virginia
awesome looks like Virginia fixed that
problem at least for now in a cinch and
speaking of cinch I would strongly
recommend you check out singe right now
go to cinch.com use promo code Knowles
lot of family gatherings lined up the
last thing that you need when hosting is
turning on the grill and finding out
that you're out of propane that is where
our friends at cinch come in cinch is a
propane grill tank Home Delivery Service
they deliver propane tanks right to your
door on your schedule and do not require
any long-term commitment or subscription
plus delivery is completely contactless
you don't have to wait around at home
track the order on the Cinch app from
anywhere I remember as a kid I used to
be kind of nervous when you go pick up
the propane tank and be in the car so
don't don't make any sudden moves so if
we don't get hit here I don't want to go
up in a ball of flames well I really
like the idea you just you just order it
pre-order it's super simple on your
phone just shows up at your door you
don't need to worry about it the perfect
summer night would not be complete
without cinch go online to cinch.com or
download the Cinch app to order new
customers get their first tank exchange
for just 10 bucks with promo code Knolls
cinch.com or download the Cinch app use
promo code nulls to get your first tank
exchange for just 10 bucks there's a
limited time offer you must live with an
essential service area to redeem it go
to singe.com offer for details you might
have been one of the tens of millions of
people who watch Netflix's hit show
making a murderer if so then you are
going to love daily wire Plus's new
exclusive 10 part docu series with
Candace Owens convicting a murderer
coming this summer whether it's exposing
BLM or certain fallacies in the
healthcare industry regarding kovid
Candace Owens has never been afraid to
challenge The Narrative she will find
the truth wherever it leads when Candace
found out that key facts may have been
omitted in Netflix's series
she set out to uncover the real story
behind the notorious Steven Avery case
the end result is convicting a murderer
you will not want to miss it right now
there's never been a better time to
become a daily wire plus member sign up
now for convicting a murderer you will
receive an early bird discount of 25 off
your daily wire Plus Membership you will
also get all the other premium content
from daily wire plus including greatest
Li ever sold what is a woman the largest
collection of content for Dr Jordan B
Peterson joined now at dailywired.com
subscribe to become a member and to see
the truth when it finally comes out
it's a great solution
it insists that users of porn websites
and Target PornHub because it's the big
one insist that they submit
a government-issued ID
and then they can use the website that's
a good first step because they're going
to be a lot of people who recognizing
that porn is extremely shameful just
won't do that and then
they will be they will have less access
to porn they will be less impelled to
look at porn pornhub's uh profits will
decrease PornHub will have a more
difficult time maintaining their service
and you'll you'll drive it ever further
toward the margins of society
great what's the problem with that I
remember when these proposals first
started to come up
five six years ago when it really
started to gain some traction on the
right and some of us conservatives
advocated these policies and the more
libertarian minded more sort of I don't
know 2010 era conservative types uh
libertarian types they said no this is a
horrible horrible idea
why
we know that this works this is exactly
what the libs did with cigarettes this
is exactly what they did they said
you've got to present an ID and you've
got to be 18. no forget about that you
got to be 21. now pretty soon you have
to be 45 to buy cigarettes in New York
you can't even buy tobacco if you were
born after a certain age that's one of
the proposals the libs have put forward
there you can't buy flavored tobacco you
can't buy this gun we're going to
increase the taxes on Tobacco we're
going to lump this then the other thing
and I'm not a cigarette fan I've never
been a big fan of cigarettes you know I
love cigars but cigarettes have never
been a huge fan but I'll tell you this
for certain porn is way more dangerous
than cigarettes
cigarettes mess up your body
you have a minor effect on the soul
relative to porn which melts your brain
and turns you into a complete dummy like
a drooling idiot you know that
completely burns out your reward centers
and destroys the way that you look at
women and is probably responsible for a
lot of the sexual dysfunction that we
have in our country today
yeah it's way you're going to regulate
cigarettes that way and it worked well
how about we just do what Virginia is
doing right now
and let PornHub whine about it really
really smart stuff speaking of weird sex
stuff
pride month is over
but pride month is never really over is
it anymore it's just Pride
all the time it's just oh it's it's
Pride Nation now according to Joe Biden
We're a nation of Pride and one group
that apparently was left out of the
pride festivities
they're coming back with a vengeance
this would be the asexual community
this is a post that just went viral on
social media from the Yasmine Benoit
who says asexual people
deserve equal rights we deserve legal
recognition
we deserve protection thank you
stonewall UK for allowing me to march
with you again at pride in London today
and for helping me to bring about this
change
this is what asexual looks like
I stand with stone wall
emphasis on all
there's no there's no end to it guys
there's no end if
if the the people who by definition
don't engage in sex
are insisting on becoming
one of the identities of the sexual
Revolution
there's no end
it just this just goes on forever and
ever what rights don't the supposedly
asexual people have
not there's no what legal recognition
could they even possibly
have I do it doesn't it's just
griping and whining and solipsism all
the way down that's what it is it's the
idea that you in your ever multiplying
ever more particular
appetites
are not only the only person that
matters but maybe just the only thing in
the world the only thing that's really
really real
now that one's kind of funny
onto the darker side of sexual
pathologies
there was this awful shooting over the
weekend and this was in Philadelphia and
there wasn't a ton of news on this right
away that people weren't really seeing a
lot in the headlines it turns out that
this killer who shot four men dead and
end a 15 year old boy allegedly in the
king-sessing neighborhood on the evening
Eve of the Fourth of July is a
[Music]
jensaki
who was the White House Press Secretary
now she has a show on MSNBC
Jen Saki
is bringing to her political commentary
all the gallibness all the shallowness
and the talking points
that she brought to bear as the White
House Press Secretary she's got a new
line against conservatives
and it's on the conservatives who are
talking about social issues
and who we're pointing out that certain
groups in America
don't really like to go along with some
of the radical social ideologies
well she's bringing all of her
sophistication to Bear to say this is a
new line write it down the GOP
is racist now that's a bad look for her
I think it's a bad look for the
Democrats to use these stupid shallow
lines when you want to look good
you got to check out geniusell right now
go to geniusell.com our friends over a
geniusell sold out of their Dark Spot
Corrector and our listeners have been
begging for a restock begging on their
hands and knees well I've got great news
just in time for the summer
it's back geniusell's famous Dark Spot
Corrector has not won but three Cutting
Edge ingredients and goes to work fast
to Target sunspots dark spots liver
spots and even old discoloration both on
your face and your hands you can now
enjoy your summer sun Beach and
barbecues without embarrassing spots
geniusell's most popular package also
features their summer Essentials such as
the best-selling Ultra retinol
moisturizer with a powerful retinol
alternative for safe use in the sun
you'll be amazed how quickly you will
see results or 100 of your money goes
back guaranteed go to genucel.com
Knowles right now get your dark spot
corrector in the geniusell most popular
package that is geniusell.com Knowles
right now save over seventy seven zero
percent off Junior cell's most popular
package all orders will include a
mystery luxury gift while supplies last
geniusell.com Knowles
my favorite comment yesterday is from
Vox umana to Abel who says
I love that Michael refuses to use a
laptop during his show and still prints
out every single story I'm glad you love
that I do it very intentionally I have
since day one of this show I don't like
being in front of a screen all day I
think it makes me into a cyborg and
makes me dumb so I don't want to do that
and I also don't like it when I'm in the
audience I don't like watching people
read off a screen
to me it seems kind of Shifty you know
like people are getting updates the
whole time being told what to say by
nefarious Powers even if that's not
really happening it's just it's I don't
want
to watch a speaker be totally plugged
into the Matrix okay I want good
old-fashioned cards I want good
old-fashioned articles printed
I won Real physical stuff that can't be
updated this is why I buy physical books
now I don't I don't use my Kindle
anymore I use my Kindle because the libs
and the increasingly
technologically sophisticated powers
that run our political order they could
just go in and edit books they do it all
the time I don't want that I want the
good old physical copies I recognize the
trees are a renewable organic resource
and we need to make sure that we cut
them down and print stuff out because
otherwise they're going to turn those
forests into parking lots now
is the GOP racist this is the charge
from the libs for the last uh ever for
forever and they're still keeping it up
gen sake making this claim on MSNBC
very old GOP Playbook that Harkens back
to president Richard Nixon's Infamous
southern strategy during his campaign
for president in 1968 the Republican
Party made a concerted effort to reach
white Southerners who used to vote for
Democrats by playing to their fears of
African Americans and the civil rights
movement and it worked by pitting one
group of Americans against another the
GOP successfully managed to split off
Southern whites from the Democratic
party now decades later the right wing
is Reviving that same Playbook this time
with Muslim Americans and trans people
hear me out here the GOP is trying to
recruit Muslim Americans a community
that makes up less than two percent of
the US population against another tiny
marginalized group of Americans
transgender people
huh
oh oh and let me do where's my pen I
gotta write that down what a fresh
Insight GOP racist southern strategy
here their target good grief I mean if
this is if this is what gen saki is
bringing to her role at MSNBC they might
as well just play reruns of Rachel
Maddow Rachel Maddow actually it's much
more interesting than than these lesser
commentators they might as well play
reruns of I don't know Lawrence
O'Donnell or Chris Hayes or Chris
Matthews or it's all the same nonsense
you could go back to an episode of MSNBC
from 2006 they'd be saying the exact
same nonsense that jensaki is saying
here
the GOP they're splitting off they're
doing it with the GOP doesn't need to
split Muslims off of the LGBT community
okay Muslims don't need Republican
politicians to do that Muslims it turns
out have their own beliefs Muslim
they're real people they have intellect
they have will they have a vision of the
world that is not your vision
jensaki and the Liberals
and much as you might like to dominate
their vision and suppress their vision
and substitute out their understanding
their 14 year 1400 year old
understanding of human nature in the
world for your much newer vintage of
liberalism
you don't get to do that that's probably
not going to happen
and one aspect of Islam that Islam
shares with Judaism and Christianity and
many varieties of virtuous paganism is a
an opprobrium for
sexual eccentricity and deviancy
and one thing that Islam shares
with Judaism and Christianity and
even virtuous paganism is an
understanding of human nature such that
uh
your soul is not in radical opposition
to your body at the level of sex and
gender
you don't need the GOP to do that
people have their own
their own views
think about the Liberals can't
understand this the the Liberals much as
they malign colonialism
the Liberals have a much more intensely
Colonial flattening
universalizing point of view than pretty
much anyone else in the world including
Christians
liberalism in in many ways it's not
exactly a Christian heresy but it is a
perverted offshoot of Christianity it's
why liberalism arises in the Christian
West but it's a it's a perversion and in
the inversion of Christianity in all
sorts of ways and it makes an a God out
of man rather than having man recognize
God as his one true God and and it
exalts the will of man above all else as
opposed to Christianity which says that
man needs to bring his own will into
Accord with right reason and reality and
the will of God
but it is
kind of a weird little offshoot of
Christianity and Christianity is a
universalizing religion right
Christianity uh had the the oldest
flavor of Christianity is called the
Catholic Church Catholic means Universal
Christianity makes claims for the whole
world but it's not a it's not a
globalism it's not a flattening like it
recognizes
principles such as subsidiarity it
recognizes the legitimacy of civil
Authority
it respects custom and tradition
it doesn't try to flatten everything
there are all sorts of Rights in
Christianity there are all sorts of uh
local flavors
while at the same time there being an
insistence on one church with one Vicar
of Christ and one holy sacrifice in Mass
so
and one God obviously uh
liberalism just takes all that
particularism it takes all that respect
for local Authority respect for
tradition respect for the the
civil Authority it's just liberalism
just rips all of that out and says no
everybody's got to be exactly the same
not even down to this nation has to be
indistinguishable from this nation not
even down to this race has to be
indistinguishable from this race down to
this sex has to be indistinguishable
from the sex down to everything it just
flattens
it flattens it all much much more
Colonial than anything the Christians
have ever done now
speaking of MSNBC I have got to get to
this story
Joy Reed
Joy Reid very upset by the Supreme
Court's decision to get rid of
affirmative action in college admissions
and Jerry Reed's upset because she says
with that affirmative action she never
would have gotten into Harvard
let me just be clear I got into Harvard
only because of affirmative action I
went to a school no one had ever heard
of in Denver Colorado in a small suburb
I didn't go to Exeter or Andover I
didn't have college test prep I just
happened to be really nerdy and smart
and have really good grades the good SAT
scores but someone came to Denver
Colorado to look for me a Harvard
recruiter flew to Denver and I met up
with her at the Village Inn Restaurant
and did a pre-interview to get to route
to pull me into Harvard I wasn't I was
pulled in and the and the school's like
affirmative I got into affirmative leads
and it was literally not saying we're
going to take an unqualified person and
put them in Harvard we're going to take
a very qualified person who we would
never know existed and put them in
Harvard that's how I got there that's
how katanji got there that's how Justice
Jackson I should say justice Jackson got
there I didn't know that Joy Reid had
gone to Harvard
and this explains that
her
explanation of how she got into Harvard
explains why I didn't know from her
commentary that she was educated at
Harvard and that's underscored by the
fact that she doesn't even know what
affirmative action is
she says I didn't get into Harvard
because I was given an unfair Advantage
because I was unqualified but then I was
given an artificial boost and then I was
allowed in that's not no
that's not affirmative action yes it is
that is what affirmative action is
affirmative action is
you have two students
one is white one is black let's say they
have the same test scores the black
person gets in the white person doesn't
or more often is the case white person
has one test score a black person has a
lower test score the black person will
still get in such as the advantage it's
not just true of black and white it's
the white people will be punished
primarily but also the Asian students
will be punished and the black people be
given an advantage but also to some
degree Hispanics to a great degree
Native Americans though there just
aren't that many Native Americans in
America anymore
so
it's this weight of giving people who
are less qualified an advantage
she says no affirmative action just
means that Harvard discovered that
Denver exists you think Harvard
University didn't know that Denver
exists
yeah oh wow ever since affirmative
action was passed into law we unless
some fellows of Harvard College we've
discovered there's a state called
Colorado did you know and now now we're
going to send emissaries out there to
find people no what are you talking
about
what on Earth are you talking about
colleges have always recruited people
colleges have always accepted
applications from all over the country
if Joy Reid got into Harvard because she
had a perfect SAT score and she was
validatory in her class and she was
really seriously Highly Educated highly
intelligent qualified person
a lot of big ifs over here then she
didn't get in because of affirmative
action she got in based on her strength
and qualifications
if maybe she didn't have that perfect
SAT score
and I don't know I don't know what her
SAT score was if maybe she wasn't the
valedictorian of her class if maybe she
wasn't as qualified as other people
then she did get in because of
affirmative action and she might say
well it's good I damn well want to get
into Harvard and it's good for me to get
in for X Y and Z reason okay maybe she
can make somewhat convincing arguments
but the flip side of that is that
someone
who was more qualified did not get in
because she was given that Advantage you
can't have
an unfair Advantage for one person
without an unfair disadvantage for
another person and maybe Joy Reid would
say because Joy Reid has expressed
certain antipathy toward white people in
her commentary maybe she might say well
that's a good thing that white students
are disadvantaged well what about the
Asian students this is where the
Liberals really fell
fell into a trap here on affirmative
action because had it just been an
unjust discrimination against white
people given our liberal regime they
probably would have gotten away with it
doesn't make it fair it doesn't make it
right but they probably would have
gotten away with it but it's really hard
to make the claim about aggrieve
depressed racial minorities being
discriminated against when your policy
discriminates against another
another racial minority so big big loser
and now and now people such as Joy Reid
won't even be able to go to Harvard
and not receive an education much like
Joy Reed uh today is woke Thursday
isn't I thought that was woke Wednesday
now there's another one there's a
history lesson from Tick Tock that Mr
Davies wants me to get to so we'll get
to it today the rest of the show
continues now you don't want to miss it
become a member use code Noel scanner
wlas a check out for two months free on
all annual plans
[Music]